hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Super Mario maker
things are going better I mean I said
that in the last one and you know
sometimes sometimes things don't go
better but this time they went better so
let's hope that that streak continues in
that everything is good or is doing this
then what I've had in the past
yes I'm so good at this particular level
because I've done it one time before and
that's good enough for me
eat chod assbag come this way
do me a favor blast those get out of the
way then woosh woosh [ __ ] okay
everything fine everything good I trust
god damnit shouldn't have trusted that
much at least I'm not drunk anymore
alright get to this this that thing do
this thing get this thing chica what are
you - chica are you on the sock again
you leave that sock alone
that's my sock you do not chew on socks
you have pret you have your own toys how
do you need socks she goes nuts oh [ __ ]
that's all bad but that's a Yosh
that's a Yosh yes yes yeah no yes well
sure lived sure glad that happened
yeah like face freakin a hole okay I
need these I actually do okay
trusting oh that was clutch hope is
right on the edge yeah just success okay
here we go
ha okay everything's fine oh I can go
down it is that good what is this what
ours you perfect yes I don't know what
this is gonna be for but I'm gonna use
it to the best of my ability ooh tell me
it does some good oh oh this is not what
I expected damn it yeah that's all I got
damn it that was gonna be something goo
Oh
oh I can just go down there don't do
that don't do that to me now what I have
to get through this now when it's a
long-ass game long-ass level with long
ass problems
hashtag long ass problems alright here
we go
son's gonna win it how did I [ __ ] that
up how how did I [ __ ] that up
I'll answer I didn't jump properly is
the proper answer what that happened
there it wasn't for I have to put on the
dad pants every once in a while with
chica you stay you stay there you stay
right there
good stay don't give me that look your
stay okay chicas fine she's fine
everything's okay you're gonna be gosh
[ __ ] [ __ ] bags
you know the discipline bring on the
hammer of Thor every once in a while
OOP hop and there we go got easy-peasy
because there is no problem there is no
problem eat chod get here do this thing
do for me please do it for me chica I
told you to lay down what are you doing
here I said go lay down where are you
right now you need to be laying down in
your bed I've got a show to do you are
not helping as far as I know you're not
helping
oh no maybe somebody i won't forgot oh
forgot oh I was a little too close okay
so the cool thing is there's a Yosh
right here and I'm gonna blast you in
the next Tuesday you eat that shoot that
out there get that done dodge it on the
way back [ __ ] [ __ ] come back
Yosh
that buh-ba-ba-bah [ __ ] stop this stop
this craziness don't just go down
sorry Yosh I meant to come back for you
but I guess I'll do it next
okay I've gotten good at the precise
jumps she could go lay down do you know
no no no no no no go straight into the
here we go that's better
Dukey Oh got it
it's weird with the twirly jumps okay
got that okay so the trick is whoa not
to go down there at all I thought I
needed to go down there why did I even
think I needed to go down there I
obviously didn't need to go down there
ah it's dance it's dancing stiff it's
death hello sir how are you doing oh god
damn it why is it got to be like this
where's gotta be like this well you got
to put me on one last we need that give
give to me give to me see you okay at
least I'll be safe from damage and may
be safe from something don't rose my
nuggets where's this gonna go how's it
gonna [ __ ] me
it's gonna [ __ ] me like this I probably
needed that did I needed that I don't
know if I needed that don't don't don't
you don't you know don't you
oh god this ain't this ain't gonna be
good is it I'm just gonna just gonna
stay here everything's cool
everything's 100% cool everything's cool
whoop yeah okay that ain't cool just
gonna go over here now uh-huh uh-huh
cool yeah totally fine you do your thing
well don't come no no no don't do that
don't do that don't do that don't do
that it's okay cuz there's a there's a
flower in there somewhere
yeah damage boosting to the best okay
did he die
did he die he died nope he didn't die
maybe he died I don't know it seems like
he did yes yeah what what that doesn't
make any sense get out of here
get out here burn you bastard
I did it okay whoa doing good so far
doing good I'm gonna make it to the end
of the challenge and I'm gonna make it
there in good time I promise you that I
promise that was a tough one because it
was so long anyway so now we got Mystery
House can I don't like the sound of
Mystery House confusion because that
just makes it sound like there's Oh No
second one I don't want to do this I
don't wanna do this is gonna be random
chance I don't want to do it it's so
douchey it's common here it's a secret
to everybody that's that's what the
comment says is just it's a secret to
everybody really that's incredibly
helpful thank you well then at least I
know it's the top one but if I go past
the top one it's another series of
choices I'm just gonna be just going to
be incredibly pissed
incredibly fused okay try this okay is
there gonna be he's gonna be oh no no oh
I did good VIN thing I think that's what
he wanted me to do is that what I wanted
me to do no apparently not I'm gonna go
for it
nope that's well yeah I'm gonna go with
us screw this one I'm gonna go with 100%
screw this one I'm gonna go with screw
that I know it's gonna be even do sure
god it's gonna be someone one one oh my
god
well [ __ ] I miss them all what oh okay
alright then whoop it's all just spin
jumping this is perfect I like this so
much I can't this series I can't read
the title I can't know if there's a
secret in there or not is it is it there
like they're just secret secret here
secret secret anywhere here
Chickie's good Nancy I think she needs
to go outside what am i yeah Wow but
what am I supposed to do it is I can't
do this to me I did the thing oh let me
just clear the top just in case you
never know
oh well why did it give a bad noise then
why did it give bad no hello okay
doesn't seem particularly hard did that
what checkpoint I like checkpoints whoa
good okay so now I'm actually doing it
but oh I'm supposed to be small there so
I need to damage okay then I need to
yeah okay I know what I need to do don't
don't do that don't do that
do anything but that okay so I got this
and I know I need this over here
probably for some reason oh I got it I
gotta go I got it I just bombed right in
the face I didn't know you were so close
what a good pop what a good poop what a
good puppy
what a good poopy butt what a good poop
poop who would you bunker buster' who
would you keep your big ugly bow oh yeah
bunky bow she's good idea he's good
okay one more will you do this we knew
this I don't know what I'm trying to
convince oh you knew this chica don't
know chicken come on chica leave it
leave it
good good girl good girl oh god that
sounds bad okay I was very scared oh
yeah I didn't realize there was a spike
there who's being blocked by all the
numbers and such okay survival simulator
I don't like the sound of that
maybe it's like these seem dangerous but
they actually aren't one can hope one
can truly hope well this isn't gonna
last long okay so I see I see
oh god oh gosh oh yeah shadow No
okay cool I guess like oh I could just
go home one at a time I didn't need to
run all the way through that was that
was a stupid move on my part that was
just that was just ignorance oh I could
have just easily not done any of that is
that like a an item down there that I
could use probably okay I forgot which
one was which why do I need to go
through this why do I need to do this
maybe there's another way around this
that's not so douchey and maybe maybe
maybe there's like you know a something
in that block one could hope one might
hope once one's not gonna hold much hope
I could just go the other way around why
am i doing that I could just go the
other way around it could go up and I'm
puffing around and I could go up and
above and around but I'm not gonna go up
and above and around because I'm so
stupid that I'm not gonna do that like
this easy-peasy
okay well this was not worth it this was
easily not worth it oh hello you can get
around that I don't know if there's a
point to that but I'm gonna get around
that I can do that I can do that I can
do that I can do that I can't believe
that easily easy peasy lemon squeeze me
okay well no you don't know you don't
know you don't what's over here
it looks like that oh hello this is this
looks cool Oh stupid wiggler down my way
okay so there's no point in going over
there so I'm gonna go the other way
around all right
uno mas well let's go the way that we're
supposedly supposed to go with the party
musica bangle and uh blares - god damn
it [ __ ] me in the bond hole sorry I
didn't mean that everybody just don't
take that out of context and don't put
it in the context as I get for you just
completely ignore the fact that any of
that actually happened and we're just
gonna move on with our lives sound good
sound good [ __ ] not gonna get me this
time I'm gonna take my time with it
so I can go right down there
whoa how is closed okay I got it what
good does that do me
well friggin duck oh no you didn't tell
me that they were spinning what was I
supposed to do after that son of a [ __ ]
well how am I supposed to get the other
one it doesn't make it easy oh maybe if
I just get the key first and then go
away I can just go in one of these doors
and then figure out what the hell I'm
supposed to do later much after the fact
yeah let's just let's just pretend like
we know a [ __ ] right on my grundle
why are my grundle why is there one down
there how am I supposed to get it down
out of the pit there's a bunch of
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's [ __ ] oh I
know because I can only go over here
once that thing is not gonna be there oh
no it'll be there trust me I'll be there
trust me all I ask me then not good is
the opposite of bad [ __ ] what [ __ ] your
magic screw this okay I'm done for this
episode this is a bunch of [ __ ]
bunch of stupid [ __ ] so thank you
everybody so much for watching I'll see
you in another video this one where I'm
gonna finish up this challenge in no
time thanks again and as always I'll see
you in the next video
Bismark fire always breaking the game
over and over again so hopefully we can
work out all the issues jump over
something that's not a mr. kitty that's
not a kitty that I want